Here's a truth that no writer wants to
admit. Your knowledge and expertise is
useless if you don't know how to package
it into clear writing. But when this
expert, who had never written before,
learned a few simple writing hacks from
his friend, the legendary author Cormack
McCarthy, it launched him from obscurity
to a thought leader. His article got
published in the Harvard Business
Review, and over 20 years later, it's
still one of their most read articles of
all time. So, in this video, I'm going
to reveal 12 non-fiction writing hacks
that helped this unknown researcher
become a leader in his field. Because
you can have the best idea in the world,
but if people can't understand it, it
might as well not exist. By the way, if
you're new here, my name is William. I'm
an English professor and I help
non-fiction writers write well. So, if
you want to learn about the art and
science of expert writing, be sure to
grab my free newsletter, Writer Science.
Link is down below the like button. Meet
W. Brian Arthur, an economist who
figured out something huge back in
the9s. The only problem was that he
didn't know how to write about it. He
had cracked the code for why companies
like Microsoft and then later Google and
Facebook dominated the market. He called
it increasing returns. And basically the
idea is the more people use a product,
the better it gets. And that creates a
snowball effect that locks them into the
market. This idea explains how the
entire internet economy works today. And
if you've ever heard somebody talk about
diminishing returns or increasing
returns, it all links back to this
article. But Arthur had a problem. He
was a brilliant economist, but he wasn't
a writer. So when he put down his big
idea on paper, it was unreadable. So
Arthur did something unusual. He sent
the draft to his friend Cormack
McCarthy. Yes, the novelist who wrote
The Road, No Country for Old Men, and
Blood Meridian. McCarthy is the
recipient of the Pelitzer Prize, the
MacArthur Genius Grant, and he's widely
regarded as one of the greatest writers
of the 21st century. Arthur spent four
days with Cormack McCarthy, reworking
every sentence. McCarthy stripped away
the academic clutter and rebuilt the
article piece by piece, using the same
writing principles that made his novels
so powerful, but adapting them for
non-fiction. He transformed Arthur's
draft into a clear, dramatic piece that
people actually wanted to read. This is
the piece stripped of all the words.
It's just the punctuation. And it gives
us an interesting thumb print of the
article and the style in which it was
written. Now, there are a few things to
notice here. One, like if you just look
between the periods which represent a
sentence. You'll see there's not very
much punctuation between them. That
means that the sentences are constructed
very simply. We don't have these long
expansive clauses or semicolons or
anything like that. Uh the thing to
notice here is just the minimalism of it
all. And McCarthy is famous for that.
And McCarthy's tip here is to use
minimalism to achieve clarity. McCarthy
is ruthless with this. For every
sentence he went over with Arthur, he
would ask him, "Do you need to have that
punctuation mark, that word, that
sentence, that paragraph, that section?"
And they removed anything extra that
they can. And of course, writing simply,
like this is something that we hear a
lot in writing advice, but I think when
you look at a piece through this X-ray
of looking just at the punctuation, you
really get a sense for how the sentences
are built. And in the case of Arthur and
McCartney's article here, you're going
to see that it's just so spare. They've
really stripped away everything that
they could. And why is that a good
thing? Bring it back to the reader.
Like, good writing is always a function
of the reader's experience. It's the
reader who decides what good writing is.
And so the easier that it is for them to
process the sentence, the better the
writing is. So although this piece deals
with quite a complex and abstract
subject matter, the pros stays crystal
clear and very sharp. And so I've
annotated this article for us here and
I'm going to be pointing out a few
different elements in it at the sentence
level, at the paragraph level, at the
kind of logical organizational level.
Um, there's a lot that we can really
learn from this, but one thing that I'd
just like to point out at the beginning
is the way this first paragraph is
written because I I I think it's it does
such an expert job at setting up the
problem and getting readers engaged in
the unfolding. Like, you don't even
really need to be interested in the
question of markets and and
macroeconomics to appreciate this
passage. So, I'm going to read it for
you and I'm going to stop myself from
jumping in with my commentary and then
I'm going to show you what I see going
on here. So, here's the opening
paragraph. Our understanding of how
markets and businesses operate was
passed down to us more than a century
ago by a handful of European economists,
Alfred Marshall in England and a few of
his contemporaries on the continent. It
is an understanding based squarely upon
the assumption of diminishing returns.
Products or companies that get ahead in
a market eventually run into
limitations. so that a predictable
equilibrium of prices and market shares
is reached. The theory was roughly valid
for the bulk processing smoke stack
economy of Marshall's day and it still
thrives in today's economics textbooks.
But steadily and continuously in this
century western economies have undergone
a transformation from bulk material
manufacturing to design and use of
technology from processing of resources
to processing of information from
application of raw energy to application
of ideas. As this shift has occurred,
the underlying mechanisms that determine
economic behavior have shifted from ones
of diminishing to ones of increasing
returns. The thing that I really like
about this opening passage is the way it
sets up the problem. And one of the
things that I teach in my creative
non-fiction writing class is that for
readers to read, they need to perceive
the information as valuable. So one of
the mistakes that a lot of writers fall
into is that they just provide a ton of
information and it's not really
motivated towards anything that readers
care about. So in order to pos so the
the idea let's grounded in this essay
the idea that the writer uh Arthur wants
the reader to care about is increasing
returns. He wants everybody to
understand how this idea is important.
And so the way that he does that is by
positioning it as the solution to a
problem. So this first passage right
here is just an expert example of
problem construction. Look at the way
that they set up a problem. I'm going to
have some comments as well about, you
know, I have these different colors here
and I'm going to talk to you as well
about the language choices. But the
first thing I just want to track is the
way so and and I've highlighted this in
red. So anything in red is a kind of key
term for this problem construction. So
first it starts off by saying our
understanding of how markets and
businesses operate was passed down to
us. Okay? So this understanding is in
the subject position. It's the thing
that's being in question and that thing
was passed down to us. So like that's an
interesting choice of words because it's
usually kind of raggedy clothes that are
pass used clothes that are passed down
from one elder sibling or something to
another. So already they're kind of
they're not just giving background
information of like many people believe
this idea, but already we're kind of
talking about this idea as though it's
you know a used article of clothing or
something. It was passed down to us more
than a century ago. And that's valuable
as well because it's telling us that
it's a dated idea. So passed down to us
more than a century ago. Even this
phrase by a handful of European
economists. I mean handful already
sounds kind of dimminative, don't you
think? So this first sentence, it's
really doing a lot of work to kind of
subtly tell the reader that, you know,
this old shabby idea is dated and that
we need to update that idea. So it's
passed down to us more than a century
ago by a handful of economists, Alfred
Marshall in England and a few of his
contemporaries on the continent. It is
an understanding based squarely upon the
assumption. So all these words in red
are what I call value words. These are
words, especially for this audience, you
know, people reading the Harvard
Business Review, they're instantly going
to recognize that these ideas are dated,
kind of, you know, already used up by a
handful of economists and that they're
based on an assumption. Okay? Scientific
scientists don't like assumptions. So
already the the the language is kind of
positioning this idea as being invalid.
So the theory was roughly valid. that
okay, it had some credibility. One of
the ways to understand the way this
problem is being developed is to think
about these elements. So there's the
status quo, right? And that's the way
that things are. So that's where the
writer is telling us, you know, here's
what we think. And then a good move here
is to give a concession. And that's what
they do. If you're going to be
introducing your idea, you don't just
want to come in off the top ropes and
say, "This idea is trash. Everybody who
believes it is stupid." Right? You want
to say it was roughly valid for that
time. And then we have this word still.
Now still is is still kind of setting
the tone, right? To say that it's it
still thrives in today's textbooks is to
say that it persists. Um it it it's kind
of still keeping on going. So all of
this language is leading up to this one
moment which I call the destabilizing
condition. And that destabilizing
condition is going to overturn the
status quo, right? It's going to tell
the reader that there's something wrong
with this idea. And the way that it's
been written, you know, our
understanding, even if you know, you're
not an economist, the way that it's been
presented to you is to say that you have
an idea, right? You have a belief. And
it's kind of a shabby belief that came
to us a century ago by these guys over
in England. And it was based on this
assumption, right? and h it was kind of
valid for this time and it's still
popular in today's textbooks but it's
likeun d but this is where everything
transitions here this is where we show
what's wrong with that idea but steadily
and continuously in this century so it
came to us more than a century ago but
in this century western economists have
undergone a transformation and then we
get very specific about what kind of a
transformation that is from bulk process
bulk material manufacturing to design
and use of technology. And then we get
more focused on what those industries
look like. And then here is the
consequence because now we've said what
that transformation is. And so therefore
we need to update our economic behavior,
our uh management practices, our
strategies. And that's really important
because it's taking this idea and it's
applying it to the needs and interests
of the readers of the Harvard Business
Review. This isn't exactly an academic
publication. It's read by a lot of um
business professionals and people who
want to take the kind of new ideas of
business and apply them in their own
strategy. And so what you're going to
find is that a lot of this article
focuses on strategy, right? The
practical applications of this. But this
is what's known as a conceptual problem.
A conceptual problem tells readers you
have a misunderstanding or an incomplete
understanding in the way that you
understand this topic. And conceptual
problems are upstream of practical
problems. So once we understand this new
model of you know we we replace the idea
of diminishing returns with the new idea
of increasing returns. Well now
downstream of that there are a number of
business practices that we're going to
have to adopt. So after the
destabilizing condition, the author
gives us the consequence and then the
solution or the new idea. And these are
the five pieces of a problem that I
think are just done expertly in this
opening right here. Now, a few other
points about the language that I'd just
like to point out. Um, in the blue here,
take a look at the consistency of these
sentences. In blue, I've underlined the
subject of these sentences. And notice
the consistency, right? We go from our
understanding of how it was passed down
to us more than a century ago. It is an
understanding based squarely upon the
assumption da da da the theory. Okay,
now we have a synonym, but it's the same
entity that's in the subject position
and it still thrives in today's
economics textbooks. So that's what's
called a topic string. The element that
you put in the subject position, it's
important. It it tells the reader what
to focus on. And I think a good metaphor
for this is to think about a camera. If
a paragraph is like a scene in a movie,
well then each sentence could be like a
shot in that scene. And for the scene to
be coherent and for, you know, viewers
to understand what's going on in the
scene, there needs to be some choice,
some some attention given to the element
that the director puts in the subject
position. One thing you'll notice in
unedited versions of writing is that
writers can often uh vary their
subjects. They're just not paying
attention to what they put into the
subject position. So, I generally like
to say that you're the writer. You're
like a director. The thing that you
should put in the subject position
should be cons you should make you
should make a choice about that and be
consistent in it because you're going to
be building the reader's understanding
of what you want them to think about
that topic. So, if you're varying
wildly, it it's kind of like, I don't
know, you're at a tennis game and you're
watching the ball go back and forth or
you're just watching a very chaotic
movie where you don't really know what
the point is of it all. So, I think they
do that expertly here and you'll you'll
see this throughout the piece, the kind
of attention that's given to what's in
the subject position. And then in the
green, what I'd like to point out is the
use of concrete language. So, um, keep
in mind, you know, we have here a very
abstract subject matter. This is
macroeconomics and yet it's so easy for
us to understand and many of us will not
be experts in economics who are watching
this video. So how do they do that?
Well, what I notice is anytime there is
an abstract element given to us, it's
always grounded in something material,
something concrete. I like to tell my
students that concrete writing is
something that the reader could stub
their toe on. Right? That's how you know
you're you're talking about concrete
things. And that why is that important
to do? Well, the part of our brain that
evolved for vision is much older than
the part that evolved for language. And
so, it's a lot easier for readers to
understand what's going on if they can
see it. It's not enough to just give
them words. We have to ground it in
something that they can see. And so in
this case, Alfred Marshall comes in as a
character to represent this whole
abstraction, this whole school of
belief, this understanding of how
markets operate. The shorthand for that
is Alfred Marshall. And there's a whole
section down here where Alfred Marshall
is going to be animated as kind of one
of the main characters. He did this and
he said that and and that kind of thing.
So every time we're given an abstract
subject, it's grounded in something
material. For an excellent example of
this, let me just show you. So bulk
processing, that is going to be a um a
kind of recurring theme in this
something that represents the old world
of business, right? This bulk
processing. And so to really ground
that, like if if this just said bulk
processing, you and I might not really
know what that means. But right away,
look at this. As soon as we get bulk
processing, we're given a smoke stack
economy. And now you and I can see it.
We know what they're talking about.
Smoke stacks, right? I'm picturing a
whole era of industrial production,
right? So, anytime we're going to see
this throughout the piece, anytime the
writer is veering towards the abstract,
it's grounded in something concrete and
that way they can. So we have we have
now a setting like you can if we were
watching a um a play or a musical or
something we can the smoke stack economy
is the background set design. It's what
gives us kind of context for
understanding the the these more
abstract elements. And actually we see a
good example of how this strategy of
having a consistent element in the
subject position done expertly in the
next paragraph. Just watch how these
sentences are constructed. And we're
going to have to notice in in the last
two or three sentences, there are some
subordinate clauses. Those provide
context to the main clause. But what
you're going to notice is that in the
blue, every single sentence, every
sentence, the subject of every sentence
is the increasing returns. And so it
says increasing returns are the tendency
for that which is ahead to get further
ahead. For that which loses advantage to
lose further advantage. They are
mechanisms of positive feedback that
operate within markets, businesses, and
industries to reinforce that which gains
success or aggravate that which suffers
loss. Increasing returns generate not
equilibrium but instability. If a
product or a company or a technology,
one of many competing in a market, gets
ahead by chance or clever strategy,
increasing returns can magnify this
advantage and the product or company or
technology can go on to lock in the
market more than causing products to
become standards. Increasing returns can
cause businesses to work differently.
And they and so although the passage has
these subordinate clauses such as more
than this and if that, right? Although
there are these subordinate clauses to
kind of break up the flow of it all, the
element that's in the subject position
every single time is increasing returns.
And this actually becomes the primary
theme of this entire essay. It's it's
really just about this new idea of
increasing returns and the business
strategies that go with it and that fits
the audience, the readership, and the
context of this magazine perfectly.
McCarthy told Arthur to decide on the
theme of the paper and two or three
points that you want every reader to
remember. The theme and the points
become the single thread that run
through the piece. And the words and
sentences and paragraphs are the needle
work that hold it together. And this is
a really important point to remember
because I think a lot of writing advice
focuses just on the sentences and the
paragraphs. But with this image of the
needle work and the thread, we start to
see how these sentences are just the
tools that are used to stitch together
this larger pattern. The focus is the
pattern, right? The theme. When you read
this entire article, the theme will be
clear. You've got the new world of of
increasing returns and the old world of
decreasing returns. And you've got a few
practical applications for business
strategy. And really, aside from those
two or three points, there's nothing
else in this piece that could be cut
out. Everything in here is necessary and
it all contributes to this single theme
and the two or three kind of strategy
points that go with that theme. I think
the next point to note here is the way
the paragraphs are constructed. I always
say that a paragraph is the unit of one
idea. But in McCarthy's language, a
paragraph is limited to a single
message. So one idea or one message. And
you can really do that. You know, for
every paragraph, you could really pause
and and ask yourself, what's the
message? What's the single message in
this paragraph? Right? This one gives us
a definition of increasing returns. This
one um tells us the you know why
increasing returns works, the mechanisms
of it. Down here we have Alfred
Marshall's world of of diminishing
returns. You you could interrogate every
paragraph and un you'd be able to label
it. you'd be able to say this is what
this paragraph is about and you could
make a list of those functions of the
different paragraphs and just kind of
skim that list and it would be coherent
and that's an important thing to keep in
mind is that you know each paragraph has
one job. Now of course with this
definition of a paragraph it follows
that a single paragraph could be a
single sentence and just quickly scan
here. Let's see if we have any examples
of that. Yeah, why not? Okay, almost
here. This can this can also be pushed a
little bit too far. There is especially
on the internet these days and kind of
subpublishing platforms like you know
Substack and newsletters and stuff there
is this um formal aspect that comes up
where writers are just writing they're
they're punctuating everything with a
new line. I don't necessarily think
that's advisable. I think writers should
be parsimmonious in the way they break
up their ideas but at the same time you
don't want to put everything on a new
line because it looks like every single
sentence is a new idea. So I think you
know in in a few instances we do see
these very short kind of truncated um
paragraphs and that's because you know
the the the function of that paragraph
could be expressed in a single sentence.
Usually in this case it looks like these
much shorter paragraphs are used to set
up you know the next idea usually
transitioning into the next section.
Now, one interesting formal aspect of
these paragraphs is we see a lot of them
open up with a question. Just find an
example of that. They're all over the
place, right? What would happen? What
would happen if Marshall's diminishing
returns were reversed so that they were
increasing returns? Right? And I've
underlined this in blue because I just
kind of noticed how endearing it is for
the writer to use questions in this way.
Like rhetorical questions can be
misused, but the the way they're
deployed in this section is a way of
bringing the reader into conversation.
Like we we see a lot of like let's look,
right? We see let's look our
understanding,
right? Like what is that doing? Why why
is why is he using this kind of formal
tone to to construct these ideas?
Because in these more, you know, formal
publications like Harvard Business
Review or wherever it is you might like
to publish, there is some lore about the
use of formal language. You know, they
say you should never say I and you
shouldn't say you and and all of that
kind of thing. There's a reason for that
writing advice. But here in this case, I
think what this language feature
achieves is inviting the reader to look
at the world. I it it it's kind of like
calling the reader alongside the writer,
you know. So, they're not arguing with
you. They're not badgering you with this
idea. They're not saying, "Hey, reader,
you have the wrong understanding." It's
more inviting and welcoming. It's more
saying, "Reader, we have been led
astray, right? We have been shown this
idea and it came from those people, but
now look, right? Look at this reader and
and why do you suppose such and such is
in this way?" Right? asking these
questions. It's very conversational and
it's a great tone to use whenever you
are doing what's essentially persuasion,
right? That's what the reader that's
what the writer's doing. The ultimate
function of this piece is to persuade
readers that this old idea of
diminishing returns is wrong and that
this new idea of increasing returns is
right. But if you write in the kind of
um traditional argumentative style
then you can put readers on their back
foot. So this is a very it so these
questions and these you know personal
pronouns and these verbs let's look at
the market and cast your eyes over here.
You know it it it's very inviting and
very warm and very welcoming and it's
very effective for uh the purpose of
this piece which is persuasion. And so
that's very warm and very inviting. But
now look at what happens whenever you
know we we we start illustrating this
idea. Let's look at the market for
operating systems, right? We have we
have we introduce a question here,
right? What if products got ahead,
thereby got further ahead? How would
markets work? Well, right away without
making an abstract argument, we go into
a concrete example, one that will be
quite familiar to the readers of this
magazine in uh what was it 1996? Yeah,
August 96. So, these examples are going
to be quite familiar. you know, Apple
and DOSs and IBM. Um, it's a little bit
dated for our purposes, but the point
here is that the example was chosen
because it will be directly relevant.
Um, and uh the the readers will be aware
of this story and that story is being
used to as an example of the point that
they're making. So, take a look. We have
here a kind of anecdote about what
happened to um Apple and uh and IBM.
And then at the bottom of that, it's
summed up into the principles that he
wants us to see. That history is now
well known. But notice several things.
Look at this language. Notice several
things. Let's look at this. Let's look
notice that, right? It it's very
visceral. Um but notice several things.
It was not predictable in advance. Um
once they got ahead, they got locked in
the market. The dominant system was not
the best. And once they got locked in,
uh, its sponsor was able able to cover
spread its costs among a large base of
users. The company enjoyed killer
margins. And now look th that
explanation of the um of the example is
now summed up with these key concepts
that are going to be in used again and
again and again throughout the piece.
Right? Market instability. Market
instability. This first sentence here,
multiple potential outcomes. It was not
predictable in advance which system
would come to dominate. The possible
prominence of an inferior product, the
dominant system was not the best. So the
the kind of key observations in this
section were summed up with these
concepts that the writer will then
deploy again and again. So this is just
brilliant. Like look at the way it's
deployed. We're asked a question. We're
recounted a story. The key elements of
that story are summed up one sentence
each. And each of those sentences are
then packaged into this is chunking,
right? We go from a familiar story into
now these concepts. And anytime you see
market instability, anytime you see the
word unpredictability, it's going to
link back up to that story. Right? And
now look at the I changed it in blue
here. They surprised me when I first
perceived them in the 1970s. Right? this
personal language. Again, it's kind of
this is a very kind of unusual tone to
find in a um in an academic article.
They surprised me. But again, it it
brings us in to the the writer's side of
the story, right? We're sitting on the
same side of the table as the writer and
we're looking at this world that the
writer has gone through. And you know,
here's an economist that many of the
readers will be familiar with. Hicks
warned about this thing, but Hicks had
it wrong. So this is this is telling
readers the value because some readers
at this point might say, "Oh yeah, well
this idea isn't new. Uh it was predicted
by Hicks in the 1939." But here the
writer is saying Hicks had it wrong.
Right? It's not going to destroy the
standard theory. It complements it. So
again, this is value language. This is
showing the reader why these ideas are
important. I I just love the concrete
language that's used throughout this
piece, right? We're we're not told about
two paradigms or two um modes of of
markets. We're told about two economic
regions or worlds. These are things that
you can see. There's the world of bulk
production and the knowledgebased part
of the economy. And I think the the
other good thing about the de the way
the writer is developing these concepts
is to keep in mind that they're used
later on. Like I almost think about
concepts in this way like pieces on a
board like a chess game or something
like that. And so the writer is doing
this work, right? They they tell a
story. They analyze that story. They
package that analysis into concepts. And
now they do that for a reason. Like now
these pieces are going to be moved
throughout the the the rest of the
piece. And so similarly here, like we're
given this this image of these two
worlds. There's the bulk production
world and the knowledgebased world. And
now look what happens. we have um we
have let us look at the two cultures of
competition in the bulk processing world
and then down here in the knowledgebased
world. So these concepts are always
linking back up. They're these pieces
keep on recurring and moving and that's
what gives the whole piece coherence.
And then down here in the green we have
an expert use of kind of an example like
a concrete it's an example of this
concrete language but what it really is
is what's known as an intuition pump. An
intuition pump is uh better than an
example cuz an example is just giving
you some evidence. It's giving you an
illustration, but an intuition pump is
putting readers into the posi into kind
of the detective position like he's
posing a question. He's trying to answer
something up here. Does this mean that
the hierarchy should disappear um in in
these industries? And it puts rather
than arguing something that the writer
has already figured out, the writer
provides us this image that we can then
imagine and put ourselves in the
position of of thinking through so that
we can see what the writer is wants us
to see. And so look at the way the
writer does that. Um we're given these
intuition pumps. An aircraft safe
arrival depends on the captain, not on
the flight attendants. The cabin crew
can be usefully empowered and treated as
human beings. This approach is wise and
proper, but there will be a distinction,
a hierarchy between cockpit and cabin
crews. This is a metaphor, an intuition
for how businesses in the bulk
processing world work. A style that is
called for in Silicon Valley will not
necessarily be appropriate in the
processing world. And so then he says
the style in the world of diminishing
returns is like a sophisticated modern
factory whereas the style in the world
of increasing returns is more like
gambling. And then we have an extended
metaphor here, right? Not poker where
the game is static. Um it's more like
casino gambling where part of the game
is to choose which games to play as well
as playing them with skill. It's not
this abstract kind of esoteric business
philosophy. He he's saying to readers
like in this new world, it's not like
you're in a factory. It's more like
you're in a casino. And that that's an
intuition pump. That's something that
readers can, you know, grab on to, put
themselves in the position of knowing
and really think through the
implications of what they're being told.
I mean, there are so many different
things you could say here. Look, just
the choice of verbs sometimes I think is
really interesting, right? It pays to
hit the market first and it pays to have
superb technology. We see that elsewhere
too, right? It pays. So again, these are
this is language that's chosen to
resonate with their specific readers,
right? They're using examples and
keywords such as strategy to signal
value. That's something as well that I
teach in my in my non-fiction class is
that um of course there are universal
words to signal value such as uh
mistake. Um even that transition word
but you know as we saw at the beginning
that's kind of a universal signal of
value. Okay. So all these red words are
value signals I think but there are also
communitysp specific value words and
that's something that's really important
is to understand your reader and
understand what words are going to
signal value to them. U depending on
what niche you're writing for and who
your reader is. Every group has their
own code words their own in-group um
signals of value. And so one way to do
this is to choose four or five examples
of pieces that are popular and
widespread among your readers and to
just look for words like this. Like why
is this piece so valuable? You almost
have to treat it like um like you're an
anthropologist or something. You're
looking through this language um for
their yeah for their own in-group code
words. And so, you know, those words
strategy and using verbs like it pays,
that is going to hit a kaching in the
back of the mind of uh of one of these
readers in a way that for me and you,
you know, we might not notice it uh
quite as much. And again, look at this
language. Let's get a little bit more
sophisticated. God, it's just it's so
inviting and the it kind of positions
the reader and writer into this
relationship of equal footing. Now, I'm
thinking of the introduction to that TS
Elliott poem, you know, proof rock. Let
us go then, you and I. Right? Let us go
reader, you and I. And let us look at
these two worlds of business. That's
what this kind of language does. It's
very endearing and it's very effective
for this mode of persuasion. And and
take a look at how this entire structure
is reflected in the structure of that
opening paragraph. We set up the problem
here. Here's the destabilizing
condition, right? There has been a
transformation. And then as this shift
has occurred, the underlying mechanisms
that determine economic behavior. Right?
So this second part of the piece, the
mechanisms that determine economic
behavior have also shifted. So we have
an a description of increasing returns.
Then we talk about the mechanisms. And
then even this structure, look at this.
I love this introduction. Sub point.
Here's what economic returns are.
subpoint mechanisms of economic returns.
We see that reflected in the opening
here, right? We see um here's what
increasing returns is, right? It's this
transformation to design and use of
technology. So here's what it is that
that sentence opens up here. And then
the final sentence um as the shift has
occurred the underlying mechanisms that
determine economic behavior. Well, that
shift has opened up here. So, what an
expert piece. And that's it. And these
call for different understandings, which
links back to the the opening word. I
This is such an incredible piece. And
there's so much more that I could say
about this, but I think the most
important thing to say about it is just
that it's fun. You know, th this is a
this is a wonderful piece. It brings the
reader on a journey. I feel like there's
a character in this talking to me, and
by the time you finish reading it, you
feel like you've seen something new.
You've been somewhere new. and you look
at the world in a new way. That is
wonderful writing and it's a wonderful
reading experience and I think that's
why this piece has become one of the
most popular pieces of all time ever
published in the Harvard Business
Review. It's important that we writers
find some pleasure and joy in writing
the way that I think McCarthy showed
Arthur how to do. But a lot of wouldbe
writers actually hate writing because of
the writing process itself. But the fact
is that the writing process isn't one
process, it's two. So to learn how to
develop a writing practice that serves
both you and your readers, watch this
video next because it's going to give
you a step-by-step system that you can
use to go from idea to hitting publish
that'll help you build a serious
readership. So be sure to go check it
out.